[Music]
most planets are round and that's just
something you don't really give much
thought to but it turns out Mars isn't
as round as it could be the southern
hemisphere
on average has a higher elevation than
the northern hemisphere so in other
words if you were to start on the North
Pole and walk all the way around to the
South Pole you'd be walking uphill
essentially the whole time so we call
this difference between the northern of
the southern hemisphere we call this the
crustal dichotomy on Mars and it's been
one of the biggest mysteries of the
planet you know it's the first thing
that you see about it and you say well
how could this possibly have happened in
2008 scientists mapping the surface of
Mars came up with an explanation for the
massive dent in the planet shown in blue
this Basin the biggest in the solar
system had to be the result of a massive
impact called the borealis impact it
blasted out a crater 6,500 miles wide
and five miles deep big enough to
swallow the entire United States with
room to spare something really big
happened in fact the entire top half of
the planets you do have practically been
blown off the only thing that can do
that is a huge collision and we're
talking the collision with something the
size of Pluto perhaps
you're talking about an impact that
makes the dinosaur killer impact 65
million years ago look pretty much like
a wet firecracker 4.5 billion years ago
the early solar system is filled with
asteroid like leftovers from the planet
building process they created Mars and
the earth one of these asteroids is huge
and it's on a direct collision course
with Mars any microscopic Martians
have just seconds to live the impactor
is 1,200 miles across and as it hit the
energy of the impact shakes Mars to its
core the entire planet wobbles like
jello as it came down it would have been
hitting into the surface of Mars as fast
as a bullet out of a gun and it would
have slammed into the surface and sent a
shock wave out that would have been
bigger than any earthquake ever recorded
it would have been like a tsunami of
rock coming out and tossing us out of
the way
the impact is catastrophic
it blows nearly half the planet's
surface into space and turns what crust
remains into a boiling lake of lava